ملايين الاشخاص حول العالم اضطر لترك
منازلهم هجره او لجوءا بحسب الامم المتحده
سجل عام 2022 الرقم الاعلى في اعداد
النازحين واللاجئين
العنف والنزاعات المسلحه والحروب وانتهاك
حقوق الانسان والفقر والمناخ اسباب مباشره
بهذا الارتفاع فما اكثر الدول التي تشهد
نزيفا في سكانها تحتل سوريا المرتبه
الاولى في اعداد اللاجئين تبيها فنزويلا
في اوكرانيا ثم افغانستان فجنوب السودان
اما السودان فلا تزال الارقام حوله غير
واضحه وسط ترجيحات بان عدد النازحين
يقتربوا من مليوني شخص ورغم ان الادعاء
الاوروبي بان دول الاتحاد وبريطانيا هي
الاكثر استقبالا للاجئين تثبت ارقام الامم
المتحده خلا عليك اذ تعتبر تركيا الدوله
الاكثر استقبالا للاجئين تليها كولومبيا
في المانيا وباكستان واوغندا الا ان ذلك
لم يمنع اوروبا من التحول الى ما يشبه
القلعه الحصينه التي ترفع اسوارا عند
حدودها وحدود دول اخرى بعيده عنها بذريعه
منع الهجره غير الشرعيه الاستثناء الوحيد
هو اللاجئون الاوكرانيون الذين لم يجدوا
صعوبات تذكر في الانتقال لدول اللجوء
الاوروبيه
فمع نهايه العام الماضي باتت منطقه
التاشيره الموحده
بنحو 19 نقطه حدوديه مسيجه تمتد بطول اكثر
من الفين كم
وعلى امتداد المسارات المؤديه الى اوروبا
يصاحب الموت اللاجئين النقطه الاخطر البحر
المتوسط الذي حصد حياه عشرات الاف الاشخاص
ممن حاولوا الانطلاق من سواحل ليبيا وتونس
ومصر ولبنان وسوريا وتركيا واليونان
باتجاه اوروبا اما المسار الافريقي الاخطر
فيبقى ذلك الخط الممتد على طول الصحراء
الكبرى ومع استمرار انفجار الازمات
والصراعات وتراجع المداخيل بسبب الفقر
وغياب التنميه وانعدام فرص الحياه بسبب
تداعيات التغير المناخي تتوقع الامم
المتحده ان اعداد اللاجئين ستستمر
بالارتفاع في غياب حلول جديه
سواء باخمات النزاعات وتنميه المجتمعات
ودعم الاقتصاد بدلا من التعامل مع المساله
من المنظور الامني وتجاهل الاسباب
الرئيسيه فان كارثه المتوسط الاخيره قباله
شواطئ اليونان يخشى ان تتكرر برا وبحرا
[موسيقى]